Humor and levity lead to deeper
connection and communication. My name is
Matt Abrahams and I teach strategic
communication at Stamford Graduate
School of Business. Welcome to Think
Fast Talks Smart the podcast. [music]
Today I am really looking forward to
chatting with Chris Duffy. Chris is an
award-winning [music]
comedian, television writer, and the
host of TED's popular How to be a Better
Human podcast. A former fifth grade
teacher who went on to write for HBO's
Wyatt SenX [music]
Problem Areas, Chris consistently
explores the intersection of humor,
connection, and empathy. His latest book
is Humor Me: How Laughing More Can Make
You Present, Creative, Connected, and
Happy. I am super excited for our
conversation. I really enjoyed getting
to know you when you had me on your
show, and I'm thrilled to have you here
on Think Fast Talks Smart.
>> Thank you so much. Yeah, it was such a
pleasure talking to you and I'm I'm
thrilled to be here in in your home now.
>> Well, thank you very much. Shall we get
started?
>> Yes, let's do it.
>> So, uh you have a fascinating backstory.
You transition from teaching uh in a
classroom 10-year-olds, fifth grade, I
believe,
>> to uh performing standup comedy and now
you host uh your own uh show on the TED
network. Uh how did managing a fifth
grade classroom prepare you for any of
this? You know, so much of teaching, we
think of teaching as inspiration and
these big, you know, connection moments.
And that's not to put that down, but a
lot of teaching, any teacher will tell
you, is clear communication,
um, clear expectations and having a
vision of what you want the class to do.
So like for the small stuff too, right?
Like how do I get tissues in the
classroom? There has to be a procedure
for that. Otherwise, the kids make up
their own procedure that is not how you
want it to go. So so much of that like
precision and vision I think has really
um carried through to all the other
things I've done.
>> I totally agree. It's about expectation
setting. It's it's setting up uh
procedures and ground rules but leaving
for flexibility uh in some of that. And
I'll tell you some of the best lessons I
learned when I was managing people came
from managing a classroom. There's just
a lot you have to deal with. H Chris, it
strikes me that really good teachers
spend time lesson planning and thinking
through how they want to take their
students from where they are to where
they need to be for the learning
objective. And a comedian in many ways
does the same thing. You have to where
you're starting with your audience,
where you want to take them. Now, the
outcome is different. It's not learning.
It's humor. It's enjoyment. Uh but I'm
curious, can you walk us through that
process that you have of how do we get
people from where they are to where you
need them to be? Yeah, it's it's an it's
really interesting to think about
because I would say it's actually not
just in my teaching and in my comedy,
but but in pretty much all
communication, at least anything that
I'm um planning ahead of time and and
going to do in any sort of performative
way, I I use the same trick, which is I
I think about like a magician, they do a
ton of work to make the work that
they're doing invisible. And for me as a
comedian, the work that you do is to
make it seem like you are saying
something for the very first time.
>> Yeah.
>> But actually, you've said it a hundred
times before. And the reason you've done
that is you're getting to the way that
gets the audience to understand what
you're saying and to take a journey with
you as quickly as possible. And that was
the exact same thing that I was trying
to do in the classroom is how do I in in
the shortest amount of time get the
students to understand what is happening
and then get them to take this journey
with me. This was my favorite lesson to
teach every year and it was a lesson
about um the Declaration of
Independence. So the way that I did this
was we were coming back from lunch and I
would gather the students on the rug and
I would say I have something really
serious to tell you. It is very
important to me that you are paying
attention in class and also that you are
being appropriate. And during lunch, I
found a note on the floor and is so
inappropriate to pass notes. It's
especially inappropriate to pass notes
that are inappropriate. I'm going to
read you that note right now. And I
would read the note and it said, you
know, you and I used to have a good
relationship, but you're taking
advantage of me and I feel like you
don't even listen to me and I don't have
a say at all. So, I need I think we need
to break up. sincerely the United States
of America. And then I'd say the
Declaration of Independence, history's
most famous breakup note. And the kids
would go, "You got us. You tricked us."
But they would remember that for like
the rest of the year, and they would be
excited for the next year to learn that.
And the reason is because it did not
seem like that's what I was doing at
all. And that's the same thing that you
try and do in in a comedy routine.
That's the same thing that you try and
do when you're, you know, talking to
anyone is to give them some moment of
delight, but to understand that this
like you've hooked them in a way where
they don't necessarily see what you're
doing beforehand.
>> I love that that analogy of the
Declaration of Independence is a breakup
note, but what you really did there, I
think, is you built curiosity
>> and and suspense. And a lot of
effective, engaging communication plays
on those two things. Well, one of the
things in comedy actually is like um
when you're first starting out in
comedy, one of the big things that
everyone learns is that if the audience
isn't laughing at something you think is
funny, it's often because they either
don't have enough context or because you
haven't layered enough elements on top.
So, the elements have to be like your
factual statement, but it's often like
factual statement plus emotion. So, like
the alarm clock went off and I was so
excited. The alarm clock went off and I
was so scared, right? like whatever the
fact plus emotion is, you get the
audience into a place really quickly
where then you can deliver the punch
line. And I think so often in all
communication, we forget that like
people aren't inside of our heads. So
you have to give them that emotional
information as well as the factual
information.
>> Absolutely. And and many of us,
especially if you're working in a tech
job or in a finance position, you don't
think about that emotion, but it really
does make a difference. I want to drill
down on something you said. you as a
comedian and a teacher who's taught
lessons over and over again, you want to
make it sound like it's the very first
time. How do you do that? What do you do
to to help make that sound this is an
authentic moment that we are having
together here even though I've said
these same things over and over again?
>> I'll give you two answers. One of which
is like just to say that you actually
make it genuinely
>> exciting and new for you. So you find a
way for it to not be wrote and routine
and a script for yourself. For me, if
I'm trying to tell a joke, I try and
figure out like how can I actually make
myself laugh, not fake laugh, but like
how can I genuinely find the funny part
to me of this story that I've told a
hundred times. The other part though is
um and this is the part that's like a
little more um calculating I guess is if
you want to make it seem like you've
never said something before, you don't
just think about the words, you think
about how you're delivering them. You
think about the way that your face and
your body are. And so taking a pause for
example, right? Like if you pause and
look up, if you go, "Huh, I see
something outside of this window."
Immediately people think, "Well, that's
in the moment, right? He paused and he
looked up." He's actually connecting it
to some sort of physical reality rather
than just saying, "I see outside this
window a tree." Right? Like [laughter]
if you go, "Have you ever noticed that
tree? That one right there." And and the
other thing is to um root it in the
other person. So, I think if you're
trying to get them to do something like
listen, look out the window, take a deep
breath,
making sure that they are actually doing
that thing and creating the space for
it. That will make it again feel like it
is real and in the moment. Um, because
you actually can't plan for how long or
exactly how they do that thing. So,
those are some of the little tricks that
I use. I
>> I love those. The one you just discussed
is really about bringing an experience.
It could be your experience of what it
is or helping them have that experience.
I like to leverage questions. I I'll ask
questions and and I don't always know
how they'll respond, but the questions
take me in the direction that I need.
So, there's some novelty, but it's baked
into the predictability of where I need
to go. Anding the emotional connection
you have to the moment, as you you
shared with the the joke you like to
tell, uh that can be really powerful. It
doesn't have to be just something that
makes you laugh. that emotional
connection and I appreciate that.
>> We'll be right back to finish our
conversation, but first a quick word
from one of our sponsors. Their support
allows us to bring you this show free of
charge. One of my favorite things about
this show is hearing from listeners all
over the world. Communication connects
us and the more people you can
communicate with, the bigger your world
becomes. So many of you are
collaborating internationally, working
across cultures, or simply trying to
connect more deeply with people around
the world. That's one reason I've been
thinking more and more about language
learning. Babel focuses on helping you
have real conversations with real
people, not just memorized vocabulary.
Their lessons are designed by more than
200 language experts and built around
practical communication skills you can
actually use in everyday life. And
because the lessons are short and
approachable, it's easy to fit them in a
busy schedule. Just 10 minutes a day can
help you make meaningful progress. If
you've ever thought about learning a new
language, this is the perfect
opportunity to start. Right now, Babel
is offering up to 60% off your
subscription at babel.com/tfftts.
And now back to our conversation.
stepping on a stage, be it a comedy
club, which to me would be really
challenging, or or even a boardroom or
or or just some office meeting setting
for many people can be terrifying. Do
you have any mindset shifts or routines
you use to help yourself feel more
comfortable and calm in those high
stakes moments? It's not like I always
am able to conquer my my social anxiety,
but in the settings where I can, right,
like in performance and um in moderation
or in an interview or or those kinds of
things, one is I can conquer it because
I've done it a bunch. And so I I have
given myself that kind of exposure
therapy of knowing that like if you get
up on stage and you try and make people
laugh and they don't laugh, you're still
alive the next day. And you know what?
It doesn't ruin your life. And most of
those people don't even remember who you
were 14 minutes after they leave the
room, much less 2 days. Um, so one is
exposing myself to it. The other is I
try and rather than like talk myself
into feeling a certain way, I try and
get my body first. So like I try and get
my body excited. So, I will like
literally like jump up and down, kind of
like skip before I go on stage. And then
I will like literally bounce up and down
and say like uh I think I saw this in a
a movie about Muhammad Ali, but I go
like from the root to the fruit, from
the root to the fruit, float like a
butterfly, sing like a bee, but like it
transforms that nervousness into
excitement for me. My body then like
metabolizes that as excitement and when
I go out, I have this burst of energy
rather than like a a freezing and
tightening up. So, I find the physical
part really really helps.
not the first person to share a physical
routine. I I think not only does it take
that energy and do something purposeful
with it, but it also gets you very
presoriented. You're you're you're
feeling it and and and that's where all
effective communication comes from. Uh
to my mind, hey, I would I'd like you to
explain the difference between jamming
versus joking. Can you explain what this
means and how it's best to lean into one
versus the other? Because the ability to
use humor is a great way to lighten the
the mood to connect with people to
diffuse situations. Talk to us about
jamming and joking.
>> Yeah. So, this is um this comes from
Adam Mastroyani who is a um an academic
and a writer who I I just absolutely
love. Um he has a fantastic newsletter
called experimental history, I think is
what it's called, or experimental
psychology. Um but he's fantastic and um
he has done academic research on why
conversations end and whether people
want them to end when they end or
whether they have ended prematurely or
too late. So I just think that's like a
fascinating research field. And then he
came up with this idea of jamming versus
joking which so um resonates with me.
And the idea is that sometimes we are
playing with each other in a way that
builds and lets the other person have
space and feel like they're in it with
us and we are going together. And that's
jamming, right? It's like when you're
playing instruments together and one
person plays the guitar and then there's
space for the bass to come in and now
there's space for the drums and we're
actually all making something incredible
together. And joking is his um his other
side which is joking is when you are
kind of making it all about you and you
are so so invested in the joke part of
it that you actually are stopping them
from being able to participate as well.
Um, so his example is like if you're a
pun guy, if someone says, "Hey, it's
pretty cold outside." And you
immediately respond with like, "Uh,
colder than uh colder than Antarctica."
And speaking of Antarctica, Ark, Noah's
Arc, you know, you're like, "What? What
are you talking about?" That's just like
not something that people can respond
to. It's just like kind of nonsense word
play and not even a good example of
nonsense word play. Um whereas if you
are taking what someone else is saying
and you're joking around with them and
you're getting them into it. So you know
they go it's so cold outside and you go
oh my gosh remember the time that you
told me about where it was so cold and
you had forgotten your coat. What did
you do? And then they say and we go oh
what if we both had to make a make a
coat out of garbage bags? That would be
hilarious if we were doing this. Then
you you're building something together
where there's space and you're creating
this world together. And I think that
that is something that for me
professionally on stage it's the
difference between like a great comedy
show and a terrible comedy show. I have
found this to be a really transformative
idea when I think about humor in
particular is to think about like what
is the humor that is not making it about
you but that is going to make everyone
have a good time? What is it that's
going to make the other person look
good? Because I think this is the
biggest misconception that people have
about humor is that the successful humor
is you being at the center and you being
in the spotlight. And I actually totally
disagree.
>> I think it's true for all communication
which is how do we get everybody engaged
and involved so that they feel part of
it. You're collaborating and co-creating
something.
>> I mean sometimes people talk about, you
know, being interested versus
interesting. And I think this is an
offshoot of that, right? How do you um
not try and make it so the other person
goes, "Wow, Chris is a fascinating man."
But instead go, "Wow, we had a
conversation and I actually didn't know
that I had those thoughts or opinions,
but it was really cool to to discover
them in a conversation together."
>> Yeah. Together we learned something and
I think that's really cool. So Chris, I
really enjoyed your book. Not only is it
very informative about humor in general,
but how we can be more funny. It in of
it is quite funny. I enjoyed laughing as
I was learning. So, thank you for uh you
share in it several unwritten rules of
comedy. Uh you talk about elevators, not
rocket ships. Can you just give us some
insight and advice for those of us who
would love to leverage humor in our
communication and our relationships who
aren't standup comedians or improv
experts? What are a few things we can do
to be funnier? My number one piece of
advice to people when they say like I
don't think of myself as a funny person
but I want to be funnier is to shift how
you think about that and to not
necessarily think like it's me telling
more jokes but um I would say try to
laugh more in your life so like find
people who make you laugh be around them
um enjoy comedy movies or TV shows or
clips like look at the absurdity in the
world so like if you can laugh more I
think that will naturally bring
funniness into your life and then you
can share the things that you thought
were funny with other people. But then
when you are trying to like actually
create the humor on your own, not to
just appreciate the humor that you found
or that you're hearing, there's a couple
of really um basic ways in which like
math plays into comedy. Comedy is much
more formulaic in some ways. There's an
art and there's a science, but there is
the science which is the math part. And
so one really basic thing is if you are
writing something and you want it to be
funny, say you're giving a toast or
something, you you simply have to have
the funniest word in the sentence come
last. And so if you say, for example,
let's say, you know, purple is probably
a pretty funny color. So if you're going
to say, and the and the car when it
showed up was purple, is much funnier
than and the purple car finally showed
up because showed up is not the funny
part of that sentence. So you want to
end with the the funny part and that
also does the second thing which is the
number one reason why people don't
actually get a laugh is because they
don't leave space for the laugh. So if
you say it at the end of the sentence
then you remember there's a period
afterwards. You pause and people will
fill that space in with laughter. Humor
is really interesting because laughter
is like um one of the only contagious
social reactions that we have. The only
other real one is a yawn, right? A yawn
and laughs are the only things that we
spontaneously generate kind of against
uh without consciously thinking of it
when we see other people do them. So you
have to create create that space where
then someone can laugh and it will make
other people laugh. And then uh on a
more kind of I guess philosophical
frame, people often lose an audience by
going too quickly. If you're trying to
give an analogy of this meeting went so
bad, it was like a lot of times people
will go to the the single greatest thing
they can imagine or the the worst thing
they can imagine. It was like I was
being tortured to death. Okay. Wow. That
it's really hard to go further than
that. And often the funniest thing is to
give kind of things in a series. So it's
funnier to say like the meeting went so
bad.
It was like realizing your zipper was
down. It was like realizing your pants
were fully off. It was like realizing
you had been nude the whole time, right?
Like I'm I'm escalating in little bits.
And by doing that, you're taking the
people on a journey where they're going
to laugh a little, a little bit more,
and a little bit more. Um, if you just
start with the most dramatic, there's
really nowhere else to go. So, so that's
something that we, if you pay attention
in like TV shows and movies, you'll see
that they very often will do some sort
of gradual heightening. Thank you for
uncovering some of the the the magic and
science of humor. This idea that the
words themselves and the placement of
the words matter a lot
>> and clearly words matter in
communication, but being strategic about
where you place the words and reminding
yourself that you need to space for
those words and ideas to sit so people
can respond. And then thinking about
this escalation and and this applies
certainly for comedy, but also in making
an argument. If you jump to the extreme
argument too quickly, you can lose
people. But if you show people how these
are gradually related ideas, that can
really help. And and the generosity you
mentioned of of just being present and
enjoying and laughing and what others
say is a great way to form that
connection. I want to take a step back
and talk more about general
conversation. One of the terms that I
really like that you shared in your book
is conversational doorork knobs. Well,
first, what is a conversational doornob
and what makes for a good knob and and
how can we use them let's say in small
talk and networking to the conversation
flow. This is another Adam Mastriani
idea um who was one of the the
interviews for my book that I thought um
shaped the whole thing. Um, so a
conversational doororknob is the idea
that you're in conversation with someone
and they give a statement that opens a
whole new room in the conversation. So
it takes it to a new place. So you're
not just dull and stuck in the same
place. You're going somewhere where
you're you're you're both entering a new
place together. But one of the things
that I think is really fantastic about
this metaphor that that he created is um
it's not just offering a doororknob.
It's also taking the doororknob and
turning it and opening the door. So it
it takes two parts in a conversation
where someone has to be offering these
doorork knobs and the other person has
to be receiving them and turning them
otherwise the conversation can't
actually go further. So an example that
he gives is kind of like the most
classic type of conversation is how you
doing? Pretty good.
Crazy weather, huh? Yeah, crazy weather.
Not very far that you can go in that.
But if someone offers something that
isn't just, you know, them focused, but
if they say, "I heard that it might snow
in July and I was thinking about the
weirdest weather I'd ever seen." That
begs for someone to say, "What's the
weirdest weather you've ever seen?" And
it also begs for them to say, "Here's
the weather weirdest weather that I have
seen, too." So, there is this real
opportunity for the conversation to go
into new places. And this is something
that I I think is such a lowrisk way for
people to experiment with having a
little bit more humor and fun and
excitement in their life is just to next
time you're in a a small talk
conversation, say something that is just
a little bit off of the expected script.
Instead of just saying, "Okay, well,
you know, we're we're waiting around. H
always takes so long." Yeah, I know.
Every time. Always got to wait for the
bus. Offer uh an observation. Offer an
opinion. Mhm.
>> A classic doororknob is like the best
soup is lentil soup. That demands a
response from people. They're either
going to agree or they're going to say
you link lentil soup is the best soup.
So you can offer something like that
that will allow them to respond. Th this
notion of offers comes directly from
improv. And I know I know you've done a
lot of that and we've had lots of people
on on the show talking about improv. But
it it really is about saying yes and and
collaborating. And many of us in these
uncomfortable communication situations
become very self-focused. It's, oh, this
is awkward. I just need to say something
instead of thinking about what's that
doororknob, what's that offer I can make
to keep this conversation going. And
amazingly, you can have a really
interesting
conversation when you put the offer out
there and let the other person take it.
If you enjoyed my recent conversation
with Gan and Sheree from the Tiger
Sisters, I think you'll really love
their show. Gan and Sheree are known as
the internet's Wall Street and Silicon
Valley big sisters. And together they've
built Tiger Sisters into a top ranked
business podcast, reaching number one in
business and top three overall in
Spotify in the US. They take big and
sometimes complicated ideas around
money, power, and love and turn them
into clear, practical tools you can
apply right away. Two fun facts. I
coached Sheree for her TEDex talk and I
had the chance to join them on their
show and I have to say it was a really
thoughtful and engaging conversation.
They ask great questions and bring a
perspective you don't always hear. New
episodes drop every Monday on their
YouTube channel and across all audio
platforms at Tiger Sisters Podcast.
Well, Chris, this whole conversation has
been fascinating. I really appreciate
your time. As you well know, I like to
end with three questions. One I make up
just for you and another two I've been
asking people for a long long time. Are
you up for that?
>> Yes, I would love that. Thank you so
much.
>> I am fascinated by comedians who for
whatever reason a joke doesn't land, it
doesn't go the way they wanted. It
bombs, if you will, because in that
moment where it didn't go the way you
wanted, you have a choice to make. You
can lean into it, you can run away from
it. Talk to me about how you manage when
things don't go the way you want set and
how can we benefit from some learnings
there.
>> It's something that people are always
really interested in is the concept of
bombing. And I get why it's dramatic.
It's kind of a worst fear. And for me, I
mean, when it has happened over the
course of my career, and it has happened
many, many times, I have handled it
badly in so many ways. Often the the
worst way is to kind of acknowledge it
too much to say, "Oh, this is not going
well." Because then the audience, you
lose them because they're like, "Oh,
you're not in control. I thought you
were in control. Maybe this was
intentional." Or to a lot of times
people will say like, "You're a terrible
audience." Or like, and you know, you
make a joke about oranges and they go,
"Oh, everyone hates oranges here." And
it's like, "No, people just hated your
joke about oranges." I think turning it
against them or acknowledging it or
which is kind of turning it against
yourself is often the biggest mistake.
And instead, I think of it as just
information, right? like how can you use
this as information about what the room
is feeling or thinking or what you're
missing that you could then provide
them? My friend, the comedian Mike
Kaplan has what I think is the best
possible response to this, which is he
says,
"I say something and you as the audience
have the power. If you laugh, it's a
joke. If you don't laugh, it's a poem.
It's your choice."
And I love that so much because either
way, it's a gift. Either way, I am an
artist making art. you are just deciding
which art form it should be classified
into. So that's what I aspire to to do
is to some version of Mike's.
>> I think that's fantastic. So it's how
you frame it. The joke didn't bomb at
all. It was the best poem ever.
>> Yeah. It was a silent response to a
moving poem.
>> Yes. I love it. The self-p protection
that that affords you is is fantastic.
>> Question number two. Who's a
communicator that you admire and why?
The poet Sarah Kay is the most moving
and beautiful live performer I have ever
seen perform. And when she is reading a
poem live on stage, she tours the world,
you are so 100% in the palm of her hand.
And she creates these beautiful images,
but she makes you laugh and cry. And
Sarah has this metaphor that she talks
about sometimes, which is that a lot of
people are trying to go through the
world in a way that is cool. They want
to be perceived as cool. And so they
they cross their arms over their chest
so like nothing can reach them and that
she wants to walk with her hands open so
that she is able to catch everything
which means that you catch the sorrow
and the heartbreak too. And that form of
communication I find to be so moving and
so aspirational.
>> It sounds like emotion and connection
are really critical in in what makes you
see somebody who stands out. Final
question for you Chris. What are the
first three ingredients that go into a
successful communication recipe? Oh. Um,
I'm going to say presence,
delight,
and attention. So, being where you are,
having fun, and then paying attention to
the person who you're communicating
with.
>> I love it. PDA.
>> Oh, PDA. Wow.
>> Presence, delight, and attention.
Excellent. Well, Chris, this was a true
pleasure. It was fun to be with you on
your show. It was lovely to have you on
this show. I think all of us can take
away some lessons about how to accept
offers, how to be present, and how to
think about the words we use, especially
at the end of our sentences. Thanks.
>> Thank you. What a gift.
>> Thank you for joining us for another
episode of Think Fast, Talks Smart, the
podcast. To learn more about levity and
humor, please listen to episode 13 with
Jennifer Oer and Naomi Bagdonus. This
episode was produced by Katherine Reed,
Ryan Campos, Alex McCarthy, [music] and
me, Matt Abrahams. Our music is from
Floyd Wonder with special thanks to the
Podium Podcast Company. Please find us
on YouTube and wherever you get your
podcasts. Be sure to subscribe and rate
us. Also, follow us on LinkedIn, Tik
Tok, and Instagram, and check out
fastermarter.io for deep dive videos,
English language learning content, and
our newsletter. Please also consider
joining our thinkfast talksmartarning
community at fastermarter.io/arning.
You'll find video lessons, learning
quests, discussion boards, an AI coach,
and book club opportunities. Again,
[music] that's faster.io/arning
io/arning to become part of our
ThinkFast, Talks Smart Learning